one of the world's most violent cities
is just across the border from san diego
over in mexico tijuana one of the
highest murder rates on the planet is in
that city and journalists are among the
many victims in mexico as a whole nine
reporters were murdered last year and
four were victims of targeted killings
in the month of january alone they
include lourdes maldondo lopez who was
found shot dead two weeks ago outside
her home in tijuana in a news conference
back in 2019 she told mexico's president
that she feared for her life
cbs news's enrique acevedo is in
tijuana's for us this morning uh with
why mexico is so dangerous for
journalists in particular enrique good
morning
good morning tony what's happening here
in mexico can be described as a war on
truth only one side has ak-47 machine
guns while the other is holding a
notepad
historically most of the journalists are
targeted for exposing corrupt officials
or gang members but this recent search
in killings is fueling a public outcry
for protection for the nation's
reporters
melo the only female crime photographer
in tijuana reports for punto norte a
news outlet that specializes in crime
stories
she rushes around the city covering a
migrant camp a fire a murder
knowing that her camera makes her a
target
it's not really clear where danger is
maybe just around the border
unfortunately yes
danger is always around the corner here
but she's committed you're more afraid
of staying quiet
exactly i would be more afraid of not
facing their reality
part of that reality funerals for
colleagues
just this past sunday a public mass for
two journalists was held
news photographer margarito martinez and
veteran reporter lourdes maldonado
executed only six days apart
at least 148 journalists have been
killed in mexico since 2000 and 90 of
those crimes remain unpunished
according to a report by the department
of justice as many as 70 percent of all
the guns used in violent crimes in
mexico are traced back to the u.s
mexico's government filed a lawsuit last
august accusing gun manufacturers in the
u.s of facilitating the trafficking of
weapons to criminal organizations in
mexico but lawsuits don't solve the
problem of mexico being one of the most
lethal countries in the world for
journalists
in a statement the committee to protect
journalists called upon mexican
authorities to act immediately we were
covering this story here in tijuana and
a fifth journalist was killed over the
weekend but his debt is not being
treated as a crime against journalists
because it appears he was just in the
wrong place at the wrong time
that shows you how the violence against
journalists is connected to a larger
cycle of violence here in mexico tony
yeah enrique the numbers bear repeating
four journalists in targeted killings in
the month of january nine murdered last
year alone you're there as a journalist
yourself it's not lost on me and i
wonder what else is the government doing
there in mexico to help protect
journalists
well they've created a mechanism of
protection for journalists who feel that
their lives are in danger i asked one of
those journalists if he had a panic
button or some sort of communication
with authorities in case something
happened and he said it's basically a
group chat between journalists where
they take care of each other and let
each other know if something's happening
you know you can imagine how difficult
that is in these conditions
yeah it sounds like that'd be good for
the mind but not necessarily that
protective for the body i hope more is
done enrique acevedo with an eye opening
report from tijuana enrique thank you
very much